because I always wonder because I I
think I told you I told because I I feel
like you and T rail
Oh shot the back on fig Muni my brother
I feel like you guys
are very much
um when I look at like drink Champs on
the East Coast I feel like you guys are
you guys can be that uh over here for
sure because I feel like you guys are
are very
um
you guys each have your own connections
not only to obviously the rap game but
also just to the street side and I feel
like you guys are both very reasonable
guys as to where most people who come
from like a [ __ ] background or a Hoover
background there's not a lot of Reason
like like I feel like you guys have you
have you guys ever like the the thought
process of like what if the no jumper
thing goes away tomorrow are you guys
like has that ever been like a oh we a
team you know shout out to smack too we
pushing this whole fig munity line you
feel me that's gonna go you know beyond
just what we do and other stuff too and
one thing I like about t-real is um
he's he's just like he's a parallel with
me yeah meaning like people known him as
being the best friends of certain
popping artists you know what I'm saying
and people kind of know you as the guy
with OT exactly and Trey Songz and Joe
Moses and Wiz Khalifa and Hayden around
with Tory Lanez yeah yeah like shooting
Feats yeah yeah yeah I mean you neither
here or there you feel me but no I've
always been a number two guy for sure
and I've embraced that because I'm like
I'm one of the people where if I see my
homeboy is sitting here doing dope [ __ ]
if I can assist him in any type of way
I'm cool I can play the background
because he once again it goes back to
having that faith and knowing like you
know I always knew you're going to be in
position you're going to be number one
it doesn't matter when it's going to
happen right but you're going to be
number one so you know I see my brothers
they need some assistance I'ma help them
out I'm gonna be hype man I'm gonna I'm
gonna do the social media [ __ ] at one
point in time I was posting all Joe
Moses [ __ ] you feel me I was hype man
for him I'm some you know when he ain't
never whip you feel me me and him
thugging it out my baby mama car we
driving around everywhere same as OT we
taking the whip we going places and
that's the type of person I am so I feel
like Tyrell too you know he's always
been a number two guy and we know what
it's like when you not really around
them certain artists no more how a
[ __ ] change on you how they
start looking how they look at you it's
like nah [ __ ] if you're not around your
homeboy we don't want nothing to do with
you you know what I'm saying you felt
that yeah I felt that before I just feel
like everyone loves you yeah but you
know the DJs but it was certain
individuals were like nah they wasn't
really [ __ ] with me it was cool it
wasn't no beef right but like to where
how I used to see people and they were
showing me super super love it wasn't
like that but people always remember
like man you always been a cool guy so
as they see me coming up they like okay
you know we'll [ __ ] with them we'll [ __ ]
with him and [ __ ] like that